MINHAZ KAZI: Welcome
to DataVis DevTalk.
I'm your host, Minhaz Kazi.
Our today's guest is Sarah Liou.
Sarah lives in Toronto,
Canada, and attends
McMaster University.
There she is working towards
a Bachelor of Commerce,
majoring in marketing.
Sarah is also one of the winners
of the Visualize 2030 contest.
With Sarah's love for
animals and passion
for the environment, she
was excited to create
a visual story that
would drive awareness
to these important causes.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Sarah, welcome to the show.
SARAH LIOU: Thank
you for having me.
MINHAZ KAZI: So tell the
audience a little bit
about yourself.
What are you busy
with these days?
SARAH LIOU: Yeah, so I'm
currently a commerce student
at McMaster University.
And I am currently
on internship.
So I will be returning to school
for my last year in the fall.
Once I graduate,
I'll hopefully be
looking to start my career
in something in marketing
or maybe something
in the digital space.
MINHAZ KAZI: So how did you
become interested in data
visualization in
the first place?
SARAH LIOU: So at my
organization currently
where I'm interning, I have
had a couple of opportunities
to create different
dashboards using Data Studio--
for instance, a sales
performance dashboard
and a dashboard on seeing where
our leads are coming from.
So that is what forced
me to learn more
about data visualization.
But also, we-- collectively
as an organization,
we occasionally do
data visualization
for fun and to
practice our skills.
So being able to see other
people's more creative works
of data visualization
is what really
got me excited to
try it myself, as I
like creating things that
are visually appealing
and fun to look at.
So that was what really
excited me to learn more.
MINHAZ KAZI: What has been your
experience with Data Studio?
You mentioned that the
organization you're working at,
that's where you got
introduced to the tool.
But as you've used
it more and more,
what do you think about it?
What has been your overall
experience with this?
SARAH LIOU: Yeah, so Data
Studio is a great tool.
It's basically the only
data visualization tool
that I use because
it's so simple to use.
And it's really
easy to get started.
And you really just
get this blank canvas,
and you can go
wherever you want.
You can make something
very simple and plain
and just get right to the point.
Or you can do
something completely
different and
creative and turn it
into kind of like a piece of
art, but also showing data.
So that's what I really love.
And, like I said, with
the drag-and-drop features
and the different
filtering options,
you can really completely
transform a basic chart
into something that's
interactive and something that
just kind of goes with the
flow of what you're trying
to tell in your narrative.
MINHAZ KAZI: Congrats on
being one of the five winners
of the Visualize 2030 contest.
SARAH LIOU: Thank you.
MINHAZ KAZI: Can you
take the audience
through the visualization
that you built?
Like, tell them about
the story that you're
trying to tell throughout
this entire dashboard.
SARAH LIOU: Yeah, so let's
go ahead and get into it,
and I can go through that.
So here's my data
visualization that I submitted.
So I focused on a total of four
of the Sustainable Development
Goals.
So I discuss how by
achieving the one goal--
one of the targets in
the Zero Hunger goal
is to improve our
agricultural practices
and make them more sustainable.
So by achieving this
one, we can work
towards three other goals of
climate action, life on land,
and having clean
water and sanitation
available to everyone.
So as I was going
through, I realized
that agriculture doesn't just
affect the actual climate
change, but it affects
so many different things
in our environment.
So I wanted to display this as a
little roadmap that we can work
towards achieving these
goals in a future state,
and the different
roadblocks that
are getting in the way of
actually achieving them.
So for instance,
agricultural practices,
they contribute to many
greenhouse gas emissions.
And we can see that
they increase over time.
And in regards to livestock
production in particular,
as it increases around the
globe in every single--
in almost every
country, we can see
that there is a positive
correlation between livestock
production, as well as
the total greenhouse gas
emissions in our atmosphere.
And when we focus
on life on land,
we can see that here, in
1990, the agricultural land
and forest area were
almost equal in regards
to arable land.
But if we move to
2015, you can see
that there is a significant
difference between agricultural
and forest area land use.
And I focus in on some
different case studies
to see how there are different
habitat losses because
of the land that is being
used for agricultural purposes
rather than forest.
And in regards to
water resources,
I focused on some different
case studies as well
and how a majority of water
uses for certain countries
are used for
agriculture, even if they
have water stress already.
So at the end here, I just
offered some different calls
to action on what we can
do to achieve these goals.
And by limiting our
meat consumption
and using less land
for agriculture
and less water for
agriculture, we
could really work towards
achieving all four
of these goals in the future.
MINHAZ KAZI: What do you
think about Data Studio
as a tool for anyone who's
trying to tell their own story
and trying to bring
about social change?
SARAH LIOU: Yeah, so like I
said, because Data Studio is
very easy to get started with,
and it's also free to use,
anyone--
especially if you're
in a nonprofit
or if you're doing
a charity, you
may not have the funds to invest
in a complex data visualization
tool--
Data Studio allows
anyone to learn more
about data visualization and
to actually put their data
into visualization.
So I think it's a great tool,
especially for those purposes.
And because-- just data
visualization in general,
when you're putting
the data into visuals,
it's very easy for
anyone to understand.
So you could literally
just have a chart.
And pretty much anyone
can look at a bar chart
and see that one is way
bigger than another.
And especially when it comes to
things like language barriers
and just different knowledge
of understanding when it comes
to data, this is a great way
to get your message out there
to everyone, regardless of
how familiar they actually
are with data visualization.
And it's also a great way to
get your story out there really
quickly, because you can go
from explaining in a paragraph
form of why this is that way,
and that could take, like,
several minutes.
Or you could simply just
glance over at a chart
and pull insights instantly.
And Data Studio makes
that really easy
to construct and get out there.
And then again, with the
interactive features,
that just makes it so much--
it completely changes
the experience
of the person who's
viewing the visualization.
MINHAZ KAZI: What are your
advice for folks who want
to tell their own data stories?
What kind of tips
would you give them?
SARAH LIOU: So I
would say definitely
look at some other
examples online
to get some inspiration on how
you actually want to construct
your data story, and
what's the best way to show
what you're trying to say.
But I would also say, rather
than just copying something
that you see online,
definitely go into the tool,
whether you're using Data
Studio or something else,
just go in there, look
at the blank canvas,
and play around with
it, and see what
it is you're trying to show.
And really focus on what
you're trying to tell.
And you can really frame
the order of your story
exactly in the story that
you're trying to tell.
So again, when you're going
through and constructing,
just think that you're telling a
story to someone that you know,
and construct the
visualization in that order.
MINHAZ KAZI: Sarah, thank you
again for being on the show.
You can learn more about
the Visualize 2030 contest
and look at the winning
visualizations in the links
in the description.
For more Data Studio
content, be sure to subscribe
to the GCP channel.
And you can always visit
our site at developers.googl
e.com/datastudio.
Until next time, keep
building more Vis.
[MUSIC PLAYING]